[Music]  an estimated  270 000 afghans have been newly  displaced  inside afghanistan since january  2021 primarily due to insecurity  and violence bringing the total number  of  uprooted populations uh to over 3.5  [Music]  million  [Music]  so  failure to reach a peace agreement in  afghanistan  and stem the current violence will lead  to further displacement  within the country as well to the  neighboring countries  and beyond  so there is a 29 increase in civilian  casualties during the first quarter  of 2020 when  2021 when compared to the numbers in  2020 according to the united nations  assistance mission  in afghanistan an increasing proportion  of women in children  were among those being targeted